[Music]
islands
and immunization for indonesia a
logistical nightmare
it's the world's largest archipelago
shipping shots to hundreds of millions
of citizens spread across more than
17 000 islands
actually taking a public boat is not an
ideal condition for distribution of
vaccines or drugs
it's just not safe to carry vaccines in
crowded
conditions
and the country's vaccination campaign
is highly controversial
it prioritizes younger people over the
elderly
the government argues they make up the
bulk of the country's workforce
they're the bread winners critics say
the more vulnerable could lose out
indonesia has dropped one million
coronavirus cases
and to clamp down on the soaring
infectious rate it's launched one of the
world's
biggest vaccine drives but its strategy
is contentious
the first shot in indonesia's national
vaccination program
president joko widodo getting the jab to
inspire confidence among citizens
but the plan is already controversial as
it prioritizes younger people over the
elderly
even influencers have been put at the
front of the line
they include risa saraswati a singer and
writer
who's been vaccinated since last week
along with health protocols vaccination
is one of the best solutions to the
pandemic
so i hope that with vaccination people
who lost hope last year
due to inaction and neglect will regain
their excitement
but older people are less than joyous
the vaccine
hasn't even been tested on them yet
although recent data shows
that people over 60 in indonesia are
nearly 20 times likelier
to die of covet 19 than young people
it's boring just staying at home
hopefully the vaccine
will be made available to the elderly
soon
for now i hope that apart from
protecting themselves
the young people who have been
vaccinated will also protect the elderly
and children who have not been
vaccinated
the government justifies its vaccination
priorities largely on economic grounds
we see that the majority of these young
people
are those who carry out economic
activities in supporting their families
they are actors in economic activities
so we prioritize those
aged 18 to 59.
meanwhile the elderly tend not to do
activities outside the home
because they are not the backbone of the
family's economy
the vaccination scheme has sparked
debate in the community
i do not agree the reason is because the
elderly are the ones who need it more
i agree because there is no vaccine for
the elderly
i don't think i agree because the older
ones are more vulnerable than young
people
[Music]
the health ministry says the elderly can
expect to start being vaccinated in
march or april
when the bayern tech pfizer and
astrazeneca oxford vaccines
arrive so what happens to the elderly
while they wait
what happens if they catch covet i posed
that question to
dr harapan harapan who is based in banda
aceh
so they have first they have to stay at
home and us
keep the social distancing and also if
they have the
um uh catch at the coffee 19 we
our um our health care system is ready
uh to treat them i guess it's
easier to keep an elderly person at home
rather than a young person
but what makes you think this is the
right strategy when the rest of the
world is
taking on a very different approach
because the number of vaccines in uh
that arrive in the first um
phase is very very short and also that
the number of the
proportion of the elderly in indonesia
is um it is uh
it's low compared to other countries and
also
we have the crisis in the healthcare
system that for we have to keep our
healthcare worker first we're already
seeing case numbers fall
in some countries as a result of their
vaccination campaigns
is your country already seeing results
uh not yet at all that's at all we we
just
started vaccination around one week ago
and then we we are uh and also the
number is still a very small proportion
so
we haven't like see any um you know any
uh
decrease of the number of the coffee 19
in indonesia
how much does logistics play a part here
i know it's
very difficult to distribute the vaccine
in indonesia
right now we have a 3 million
vaccination for
healthcare workers and then we have to
put them
with the provincial her office and then
the from from provincial health office
will distribute to the hospital and also
the um apus cosmos in indonesia and this
is a bit task it's hard to us
and what about resistance among
indonesians is is that a difficult task
i know
indonesia was the first outside of china
to approve an emergency covered 19
vaccine developed
by the chinese drug maker sinovac
despite
its low effectiveness does that worry
people
it is it is a big problem here in
indonesia is
uh the hesitancy not also with the uh
the the general population but also
healthcare workers
but this is the other thing that the
government should um
you know take attention and then try to
decrease the
resistance from from the from the uh
people of indonesia
and uh another factor that could see
some resistance what about halal
vaccines because of
your large muslim population
so the halal is a must in indonesia
especially for the muslims so all the
vaccine that we have to take as
should be a pass with certification from
the
muslim council so all the vaccines
should have attested by the this
organization
dr harapan harapan thank you very much
for joining us today
picking up on the point of efficacy all
those numbers can be a little confusing
the team from our science desk decided
to take a look at some of the rates
and the history of vaccines so
we've heard a lot about the efficacy
rates of covet 19 vaccines
u.s pharma firm modernist says its covet
19 vaccine is 94.5
effective pfizer biontech covert 19
vaccine has an efficacy of 95
in final trials russia's sputnik v
coronavirus vaccine trial shows
encouraging results
but what does this mean and like the
history
of vaccines let's explain
the first ever vaccine was for smallpox
it was introduced in 1796.
the disease was then declared eradicated
nearly two centuries later in 1980
and the vaccine was 95 effective in
preventing smallpox
measles 97 effective but in spite of the
strong vaccine
measles continues to spread looking at
you anti-vectors
polio has nearly been eradicated and the
vaccine is
99 effective the flu vaccine
is a tricky one as the virus mutates
regularly so people have to get flu
shots
every year to help protect against the
most common strains
generally the effectiveness of the flu
shot hovers around 50 to 60
when scientists started work on covet 19
vaccines the world health organization
said it would accept a vaccine efficacy
of just 50 percent so with these recent
phase 3 clinical trial results showing
vaccines that have
north of 90 efficacy we have lots to be
hopeful about
well yes but i knew there'd be a butt
just because the results have been good
so far that doesn't mean we can
instantly go back to life as we knew it
not everyone will be able to get
vaccinated
that includes people whose immune
systems are compromised or weakened by
existing conditions
and it will take a while to get vaccines
to everyone who can be vaccinated
so masks and social distancing are the
way it's going to be for a while yet
and now over to our science
correspondent derek williams he's been
looking into
your questions on the coronavirus
is the british strain of covet 19
really more deadly
last week the british prime minister
caused
quite a stir when at a press conference
he led
with this in addition to spreading more
quickly
it also now appears that there is some
evidence that the new variant the
variant that was first identified in
london and the south east may be
associated with a higher degree
of mortality the announcement was based
on an assessment made by a group of
scientists who advised the british
government
they'd examined new studies and called
the idea that the variant was more
dangerous
a realistic possibility they even put a
number on it
around 30 to 40 percent more deadly
to clarify what that means exactly
an official used the example of
sixty-year-old men
um and those who today are infected with
earlier versions of the virus around ten
out of a year thousand men die
if it were 30 percent more deadly the
new variant would kill
13 of those men the thing is
a lot of experts including the ones at
the press conference by the way um
they've been reminding people
that the estimate is still based on some
pretty preliminary data
and and also horribly complex
surrounding factors um not least the
fact that of course
we're pretty sure now the variant
discovered in the uk
is is more transmissible than earlier
ones and of course
higher transmissibility will also lead
to it killing more people
um simply because more people will catch
it
and perspective is also important
even if the new variant does turn out to
be somewhat
more deadly it's still unlikely to prove
to be
as lethal as the original virus was at
this time
last year because back then
we knew a lot less about how to treat
covid19
now we're able to save a lot more of the
people
who end up developing severe disease